[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
but Darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
you woke up
Becca Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here
I'm nobody I ain't even seen nothing I'm
not even seeing anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
please
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
s